The sauce, Kevin here. And I'm an idiot.
I am the Duke of the dull and dumb witted.
I am breathtakingly brainless.
I am fabulously fat headed disastrously doltish and
confoundingly prejudice.
I've spent 10 years making hundreds of videos,
celebrating knowledge and creativity.
I've highlighted the achievements of some of the smartest minds in science
and math. I've learned a lot along the way, and maybe you have too,
but for the last few weeks I've been pursuing peak
stupidity and, uh, it's going pretty well.
The fact is I hope this video makes you dumber because
sometimes being an idiot is the difference between life and death.
Here's how, hold on. I got to get this barbecue sauce off my face.
It's like literally burning my skin. Okay. Hang on. Oh, this is for a child.
Okay. I am going to smell like barbecue sauce for the rest of this video,
but it's what I do for you. Okay. Here's how.
In 1942 psychologist,
Alexander Lutens administered a problem-solving test using water and
differently sized jars.
The goal is to fill and empty those jars with water in a
combination to get the desired volume.
You've got an unlimited supply of water and you can throw out as much as you
want in problem. Number one, jar,
a holds 29 ounces and jar B holds three ounces.
The goal is to measure 20 ounces.
So you'd fill the 29 ounce jar and use that to fill the
three ounce jar three times 29, minus three, minus three,
minus three, leaving you with 20 ounces.
This is not a paradox problem to as a third jar.
This time jar a is 21 ounces jar.
B is 127 and GRC is three ounces.
We have to get to 100 ounces and that's also pretty
easy.
127 minus 21 minus three minus three
equals 100. The third problem is a little bit trickier,
but now we know how to solve these jar.
A holds 14 ounces,
GRP holds 163 and juror C holds 25
ounces. Your goal is to get 99 ounces.
You can fill the 163,
then pour two 20 fives and one 14 for
163 minus 25 minus 25 minus 14 equals hour
99. Once you're locked into the successful strategy,
your on autopilot,
fill the biggest jar and use the other two smaller jars to read it,
deuce it until you've got the right amount. It all right,
one more jar,
a holds 23 ounces jar B holds 49 ounces
jar C holds three ounces. We need 20 ounces.
So 49 minus 23, minus three,
minus three equals 20. Right? Well,
yeah, actually that is, that is right,
but it's not the most efficient solution.
We could just fill jar a with 23 ounces and then pour three
ounces into GRC and have the 20 ounces that we need
this time.
We don't need this largest jar and all learning an algorithm to
solve these problems actually made us a bit
stupider.
Lutyens found that after giving six problems that involve filling the largest
jar B and then taking away different amounts using jar a and jar
C the research subjects were locked into using all
three jars to solve each problem.
They didn't even see the simpler solution.
The final problem, 28,
76 and three with a goal of 25 could only be solved
efficiently by using the two smaller jars, 28 minus three.
Many of the subjects tried to apply their algorithm and immediately said
the problem was impossible, impossible.
They gained too much knowledge. They were too experienced.
They'd become so smart that they got stupid.
Welcome to the Einstein long effect.
Unschooling is a German word that roughly translates as mindset.
It describes the overall method and frame of reference for solving a
problem. When Lou chins conducted his experiment,
he gave a second group that problem that contains two possible
solutions as their very first task.
Most of them instantly recognized the simpler solution because
they weren't trapped in the big jar method of thinking about the
problem. It wasn't that group B was smarter.
It was that group a had learned just enough to make them
dumber. Oh,
and some of the people who were shown the simpler solution after they declared
the final problem was impossible. They got mad.
Like they got really,
really mad in his paper mechanization in problem solving Lutyens wrote
realizing it.
He is embarrassed by the blindness and stupidity showed while solving them
puzzles,
how it was possible and feels shame at having been blinded to such a degree
rendered.
So incapable of reasonable action of intelligent
procedures,
basically some were upset that they felt dumb and then
decided to take that anger out on the experiment itself
in a footnote Lutyens explains instead of viewing their
responses as stupid. Some of these subjects remarked,
heatedly that the tasks or the instructions were
stupid.
They were embarrassed because they felt stupid and they
felt stupid because they were too smart.
They'd have been smarter if they were stupider, it's,
it's a vicious cycle. The lung effect is a serious cognitive force.
And it's so strong that when a similar experiment used eye tracking
software to show whether expert chess players could recognize a simple
solution after a specific series of moves,
they literally did not even see it,
their brains wouldn't let them see it kind of like how
you can't see that my face is not flat.
This is actually a concave photo of my face.
As you can see what I turn it. This is not at all a flat image,
but when seeing straight on your brain automatically fills in
that hollow shape and projects it outward because it's programmed
to see faces that way.
Grand illusions has a hollow face Einstein masks that really shows
just how biased our visual systems are in favor of seeing
faces as convex your brain.
Won't allow you to see the hollow face for the concave shape.
It truly is because it's shortcut supersedes
reality. It's why the phrase I can't unsee.
It exists in the first place. Here's a different example.
Excuse me,
there's an old riddle about a plane crashing or a Starship enterprise
crashing on an international border and being asked where
to bury the survivors.
Your brain gets so wrapped up in processing. What, you know,
that a country's borders could be relevant in determining how to deal with the
situation that a certain number of people died in the
crash. And all the other details were used to thinking about that.
It takes a minute to realize that survivors don't have to be
buried at all.
The [inaudible] effect has created a short term illusion.
That turns a simple obvious scenario into a ridiculous
brain teaser.
Sometimes it's just better to know a lot
less in a 1999 paper called the recognition.
Heuristic Goldstein and giga runs are described a psychological experiment
asking which of two cities had a larger population,
San Diego or San Antonio,
a group of Germans answered correctly more often than a group of
Americans.
The Americans likely consider the populations of Texas and
California,
whether they thought the cities were growing and a ton of other factors,
the Germans, well,
more of them had heard of San Diego and not San Antonio.
So they figured the famous city was bigger. The end that's it.
The less is more effect actually made them more likely
to be right.
And we've just recently figured out that being dumb can make
you smart, right wrong.
We've actually known about this problem for a really long time. In 16,
20 Francis bacon wrote and know him or denim that the human
understanding when it has once adopted an opinion,
neither as being the received opinion or as being agreeable to itself,
draws all things else to support and agree with it.
Bacon didn't know the cognitive science behind that phenomenon,
but he had the basic idea, right? For efficiency sake,
your brain tends to process new things by drawing on the
knowledge it currently possesses. It's why I can't make this.
Big stand up. Come on, work with me here.
Please stand the task here is to balance this egg on
one of its ends. And, uh,
it's not really working out for me too well.
In Girolamo Benzone is 1565 history of the new world.
He wrote that Christopher Columbus challenged a group of noble Spaniards.
Gentlemen,
I will lay a wager with any of you that you will not make this end stand
up as I will make it. And without anything.
At all, I don't know why he had to be naked. This kind of weird.
They tried and failed just.
Like I've been trying.
Failing. And then Columbus just kind of
smash the egg on the table and.
Look at it stood up.
He wasn't trapped by Einstein along and neither was Alexander.
The great who solved the puzzle of the Gordian knot in the fourth
century, BC, the knot was so complexity,
so intricate, a lot more complex.
Get them this. This is a pillow case.
That anyone who could untie it would immediately be declared King of
Phrygia. He just cut it.
In half with his sword,
something like that.
The way that Indiana Jones was badly outmatched by an expert swordsman.
And then he just shot him with his gun.
Everyone has understood this seemingly forever and a recognition
of the Isilon effect is deeply rooted in Asian philosophies in
Zen Buddhism.
The term Shoshan refers to the beginners mind an
attitude of openness and eliminating the constraints of experience and
knowledge. Zen end, Dallas meditators,
try to achieve the motion,
the state of a mind without a mind free from attachments
and thoughts in Japanese martial arts,
Zen chin is total awareness,
not just focusing on what you know or think, you know,
but letting every possibility present itself,
even when it's simple,
but this isn't just about illusions,
ancient philosophy or solving cute riddles.
Understanding the impact of [inaudible] long can literally save
lives. In the 1970s,
a cardiologist named Lee Goldman compiled data on heart attack cases and
found that taking an ECG reading and answering three basic
questions could determine whether someone was actually having a heart attack.
When this shortcut decision tree was implemented at cook County hospital
in Chicago, the results were incredible.
It beat the old diagnosis method by 70%.
And the hospital found that highly trained,
experienced doctors diagnosed the most serious cases correctly,
75 to 89% of the time while the three step
quick and dirty method was right over 95%
of the time,
depending on a well-educated extremely knowledgeable
professional actually made things.
Worse.
People died because we were too smart.
We are obsessed with being smart and knowing things.
It's why I'm so curious about science and math and people.
And honestly, it's why this channel exists.
And look, it's important to know stuff and have experience.
And it's important to have a mechanized mind.
Luchin said mechanized responses have a place in one's behavior.
They possess the advantages of releasing one from the bother of finding
new responses to recurring every day situations.
They equip one with precise, ready,
and speedy responses to certain aspects of his environment.
And they free the mind so that it can more adequately deal with
complicated tasks. Hey dad.
But he then went on to say,
when a habit ceases to be a tool discriminately applied,
but becomes a Procrustean bed to which the situation
must conform. When in a word,
instead of the individual mastering the habit, the habit masters,
the individual,
then mechanization is indeed a dangerous thing.
Intelligence experience and knowledge are freedom,
and they can also be a prison that takes away your
freedom to think differently.
Your brain is the greatest computer ever invented,
but it can also constrain your creativity and limit
your potential. We all want to get smarter,
become more creative and solve bigger and more advanced problems and
everything from the video games we play to the society we
live in. There's so much pressure to be smart.
And it's just not always about that.
Sometimes you just got to get stupid and as always,
thanks for
[inaudible]. Hello.
The spring 2020 curiosity box has arrived.
You want to get yours, go to curiosity, box.com.
If you're not familiar with the curiosity box,
this is something that Michael Jake and I work on all the time,
and we're not making videos. We are working on this box. This is not merged.
This is a community of people who are interested in living a life of
the mind, Inc.
Streaking bird is one of the items that you won't get in this brand new box.
As you can see this bird very, very, very,
very thirsty and has a great hat.
You can see the Vsauce V hat might look a little familiar.
I don't have a top hat. You know, maybe I should get a top hat, but for now,
I'll just stick with this one. Yes.
More water for all. Get your curiosity box at curiosity,
the box.com, because now you're thinking,
thanks for watching. Oh,
that was gross.